what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation they have just dropped
from Universal Pictures the Five Nights
at Freddy's teaser trailer as excited as
I am for this to come from Blum House I
want you guys to leave a like for
Universal Pictures who just blocked our
Super Mario's brother's movie reaction
they have a fantastic reputation from
every single YouTuber for being the
easiest to work with when it comes to
copyright we follow the guidelines that
we do for every movie reaction and
undoubtedly Universal is consistently
the easiest ones to constantly work with
even though we know you'll eventually
Let It Be public you just love to have
some fun with us don't you we didn't
cover the Oppenheimer trailer due to the
fact for how easy they are to work with
but we're gonna take another chance here
because it's Five Nights at Freddy's so
leave a like for Universal Pictures
[Music]
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life hit
it guys
oh this is perfect oh
oh Josh Hutcherson's assistant
that's right
oh hell yeah
those security cameras we're going to
have so much fun together
whoa I want to play a game
I need some crappy Pizza
oh give me more
wow oh dang I wanted more well you know
even though Universal put us on the
Press list and they email us every
single trailer hopes we will react to
every one of their trailers
we know that they're going to be so easy
with us featuring it in a video it's
like the publicity team would want us to
isn't that ironic scheme you know this
is how they're going to make all their
money back on the movies by collecting
these YouTube earnings we're gonna put
all that not shade to the side this
movie looks really really fun you know a
lot of people don't know this about me
but all of my friends my wife and
especially would know this I'm a huge
Chuck E cheese fan still love Chuck E
cheese to this day sometimes we do go on
a date to Chuck Cheese Five Nights at
Freddy's is a very compelling concept to
me in general I've dabbled with the game
a few times I'm not the biggest
knowledgeable guy I don't want to sell
the best maybe it's not like I know some
of it I don't know any of it really I've
only played the game like a handful of
times which is a lot of fun I think I
did a let's play on that cyber Channel
Once forever ago the footage that we're
getting here yeah this looks like a big
step up from Willie's Wonderland and it
has this blend of like good old
traditional Blum House type of Punchy
horror the animatronic effects look cool
I got saw Vibes and certain elements of
it looks like we are going to be getting
rich with the lore of how this all came
to be because it has a blend of Wick and
feel like torture horror combined with
an element of like Supernatural lore
horror as well are you picking up on
these Vibes
are we on the same page on the same page
my anger that has filled me moments
before filming this it slowly disabling
to me yeah take it away John
ah yeah no this is looks uh like what
you would want from Lily's Wonderland
like I'm very curious about the saw
elements because I am not the greatest
expert however a good friend of mine
shouts out to Erica if you're watching
this is a five nights fanatic and
through her I've come to know at least
bits and pieces of the lore and I think
one thing that separates this because
Willie's wondering and obviously comes
to mind with the Banana Splits because
they beat you to the movie punch but
here I think part of the big perils is
going to be kids involved because one
thing about Five Nights at Freddy's is
there's like a bunch of really sick lore
and backstory about like kids who have
gone missing and who's like corpses are
twisted and tied up inside the Machinery
I mean I don't know if they're going in
that area of the Lord but there's
certainly a good potential to get icky
and gross and unsettling here and I feel
like you know in Willie's Wonderland or
something like that you had a bunch of
young people in Nick Cage words here you
got Josh Josh Hutcherson and then what
looks to be a few children so I don't
know like it looks like it has the punch
and the grit and the horror of something
aimed a little bit more at the R-rated
crowd but at the same time this is like
a a game with a huge fan base of young
people yeah so I feel like they're gonna
have to go as like hard PG-13 is
possible with this well I that makes me
wonder based off of what you said
Universal sucks by the way but based off
of what he said I wonder if that's why
they actually decided because I feel
like this movie will be rated R isn't
the Creator like someone who is like
really beloved still yes I thought
there's like a trouble with the the
creator of Five Nights at Freddy's I I
don't remember well it doesn't matter um
he did something I totally forgot what
he did I remember he got in a lot of
trouble and he decided to like leave the
IP behind in some way I completely
forgot but for all my friends who like
did videos on Five Nights at Freddy's
like oh I'm getting uncomfortable about
covering five nights I don't remember
any of the specifics sure but I wonder
if that's why they decided to do a dual
release with this as well I mean I know
while that worked out for Halloween we
are in a day and age now where it seems
like you can be confident enough to
release a movie in the theaters and then
at least wait 45 days for it to come out
on streaming to get blocked on YouTube
so you know God damn it
but we'll be there yeah we'll be there
they always let it go come on just like
why
why put us through having to fight and
read and then you eventually let it let
us go it has everyone at the movies and
every YouTuber I know complains about it
I wonder if they they decided like yeah
let's still do it even though that's
something we don't have to do but that
would allow the kids to maybe still get
access to watching it as well they can
just borrow their parents account sure I
mean they probably know they will like
this is even though Five Nights at
Freddy's has a huge kids fan base it's
not some I wonder if there are some
parents who are like maybe I shouldn't
have let my kids get like so uh endowed
with this and maybe you know sometimes
they do it is like you know the kind of
subject matter that for a lot of kids
like parents to kids relationships they
probably wouldn't want them to get super
involved with it I'm not saying every
pair I'm sure a lot of parents like
don't give a but I think that it is
that kind of subject of the kids like
secretly do like get involved with it
well my wife you know she's worked at
many schools and yeah she's like many
students are like obsessed with yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because there's so
many different animatronics in the
different locations and stuff but two
two I mean I think the game is deceptive
and that you are limited often to the
flashlight and the security cameras and
then you have all the lore kind of
happening around that so you know you
can have a parent walk by and just be
like ah you know It's a Spooky Little
pop-up game but that's also what makes
me wonder about this are we gonna get
like one a la you know the Doom movie
where it's like there's one first person
POV sequence just like the game are we
gonna get a security camera mode but but
I'm like is that gonna be just one scene
where it's like oh we're flipping the
security cameras or is that going to be
like a full movie mode I think it'll
just be one scene probably I think it
would get really boring and old fast and
then when it happens the crowd will lose
their and then stand up and
Applause at the movie theater and then
go praise Universal for bringing them to
life thank you Universal and make sure
this doesn't end up on any reactions is
that Matthew Lillard it looks like
Matthew yes I believe it is this is the
ironic part about Five Nights at
Freddy's trailers I know they want
people to do reactions to this and
they're gonna claim every single one so
that is the most best at least commit to
not having any coverage whatsoever of
this variety it is it is the most they
just are notorious for this like this is
again this is the prime kind of property
aimed at the prime kind of audience
who's gonna come to these sorts of
videos and get hyped up I can't wait for
that manual claimant to review this
video hey buddy how you doing I hope
you're having a great day wonderful
company hope you get a raise I hope your
boss sees all the people you claimed and
is like you know what we need more you
around and Freddy looks cool no this
looks fun looks fun little goofy little
cheesy looks like what you want from
Five Nights at Freddy's like even from
The Limited knowledge I have of it uh
this looks like what I want because I I
don't know how crazy lore heavy it'll go
like this one just has to be effective
but they if this one succeeds they have
a good franchise on their hands this is
like franchise opportunities franchise
Prime
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like what's your favorite Universal
Property and uh we'll catch you guys
soon I'm late for an event that I gotta
go to
[Music]